when you look at a cell of Sleeping
Beauty herself her hair's actually kind
of greenish and they went through a lot
of tests you know to find out what
Technicolor would do to certain colors
and how they would turn out so that's
what we did basically to we had we had
to shoot the cells again that we have we
still have on film to see how they turn
out but when you look at the especially
the ink line in the hair they actually
thick and thin they actually not
straight straight lines they have a
little bit of a thick and thin so gay it
sort of gives you this Art Deco feel to
the chiro and it's really a testament to
all of those inkers I mean just the
artistry that went into creating those
those cells is just absolutely amazing
and I know some of them are here and the
really fantastic job and I hope you can
all could see it now up on the big
screen and it's it's it's sort of
bittersweet because this as I say I
think everyone pretty much feels this
was the pinnacle of that that particular
facet of the art of animation and
because Walt Disney lost money on the
film and because it had taken so long to
make this movie he and other people the
studio were receptive to this new idea
of xerography and so the very next
animated feature which was 101
dalmatians was inked by xerox and and it
gave a different look and a different
feel and a different style that suited
that film just as well as this style
suited this film but perhaps if this had
been a resounding success they would
have continued doing it the way they had
all along they had to find a way to
economize because sleeping beauty was
about six million dollars way back it
was it was so expensive so they had to
find ways to to cut corners and with the
help of up I works and other technicians
they find found a way to Xerox the
animators drawings for the next film and
then it became sort of a sketchy a look
and went from painting to sketches
for the next very different very
different kind of a kind of look well
that was a shock of the new you know
because I hadn't seen that before and to
see really an animator sketch on the
screen it kind of took a while but what
was so good about that film was a story
was so rich and the characters and
gorillas and Pongo and one of these
great characters you completely buy into
it after all you would see what's
interesting about that also when you
approach the technology and how you try
to preserve the aesthetic as well is
when you go from something like sleeping
beauty or some the earlier titles we've
done and then approached a xerox title
like jungle book and a hundred one
dalmatians is you have an entirely
different set of issues and lying
concerns and RD that goes into making
sure that you preserve that drawing
because that's something we talked about
is it's very easy to go into a sketchy
Xerox drawing now garlic but we'll just
clean that up but it's in fact actually
seeing the skeleton behind the
characters that you want to preserve so
as much as the art of the of the the art
of the animation and the technology
behind it changed we have to adapt to
that as well today sure hey on the 24
because you're trying to preserve what
was there absolutely it was that and I
think it was very very tricky on jungle
book when we did the restoration on
jungle book because that that took it
even further you know as far as you know
the construction lines and what to leave
in and what shouldn't be left in there's
a lot more discussion going on on a
scene-by-scene basis on that film na
andreas a lot of the animators though
liked the idea of the Xerox because they
felt it preserved their pencil drawings
didn't it oh sure because for the first
time they saw their their own work their
drawings on the screen which really
hadn't happened on previous films where
you had a cleanup person taking a sheet
of paper over your rough drawing
cleaning it up then you had the inker
reinterpreting that yet again so in in
those years the film had to be drawn
three times in rough animation clean up
and then in inking and so when you come
to the xerox films you really have the
original animators
on the screen and it's given sort of a
fresh vibrancy you know fresh look